hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 german fantasy and action movie
called freak you're one of us
the movie begins with chaos at a school
building
little wendy is crying in the closet
hearing people shouting indistinctly and
siren wailing from afar
a woman dr stern steps down from her car
and firmly walks into the school
a big hole is seen on the wall with
blood traces and broken furniture all
around
dr stern finally finds wendy telling her
that everything is going to be all right
years later wendy wakes up next to her
husband lars consuming her pills then
gets ready for the day
she reads a letter about some unpaid
bills and plans to ask for her promotion
at work
lars also leaves for work while taking
their son carl to school wendy goes to
her workplace chop heaven diner elmar
her co-worker helps her with some of the
tasks she encounters angela her boss to
ask for her promotion but apparently her
request is denied unless she shows more
deserving work
she refills the beer and takes out the
trash at night at the garbage bin she
meets marek a homeless man who begs for
food marek seems to recognize wendy and
says you're one of us
wendy is puzzled by the statement but
ignores him later that night when she
heads home mark approaches her again
asking about how long she has been
taking her pills he suggests she stopped
taking the pill so that she will release
her true self and her superpower he then
demonstrates his superpower by jumping
off the bridge and getting hit by a
truck
wendy is more than shocked to see the
scene calls the emergency hotline and
immediately heads home
the next day wendy goes to her
appointment with dr stern to which she
doubled her medication doses
at the diner wendy meets mara who begs
for food again he explains that he is
invincible and cannot be killed he gives
her a leaflet instructing her to follow
the mermaid before angela furiously
repels him away although still confused
wendy tries to skip her medication and
flushes it down the toilet she stumbles
during her work and drops a tray full of
food substances
she gets angry and suddenly expresses it
by hitting the tray deforming it badly
because of her super strength
she is shocked then proceeds to hide the
tray in the storage so angela would not
find out while walking home at night she
faces drunk men who usually harass her
beating all of them up the next day dr
stern comes to her at the diner
reminding her that she missed her
appointment yesterday also reminding the
consequences of not taking her
medication which is to put her family
and life in danger on the other hand
elmar is having lunch with his father
and his father's girlfriend his father
is furious as he thinks elmar is aimless
in life and suggests he finds something
purposeful to do
meanwhile at the diner angela discovers
the broken tray and confronts wendy but
wendy threatens her using her powers
successfully scaring angela after work
wendy follows the brochure mara gave her
which leads to an abandoned water park
named neptune world that has mermaid
symbols
she discovers that marek lives there and
he has been following her all along
shown by photos of her and her family
taken secretly
mark finds her again saying that they
are humans with superpowers or special
abilities and that they are not the only
ones the medications given by dr stern
are not psychotic drugs but drugs to
suppress their powers
she has to help the others because they
are also her family
wendy denies it saying she has a normal
family already and leaves however she
keeps thinking about it and then
proceeds to break into dr stern's office
she finds documents of stern's patients
including elmar
she breaks into elmar's house and
suggests he stopped taking his
medication as well
turns out elmar is obsessed with comic
superheroes so wendy explains that elmar
can be like that too
wendy uses her strengths to help his son
from bullies lift heavy objects at work
and give a warning to an irresponsible
car parked in front of the diner
finally she asks for her promotion to
which angela fearfully agrees
meanwhile elmar stops taking his
medication and turns out he can produce
electricity he claims to be electro man
he tells the story to wendy and they
spend the night together
along the way wendy breaks an atm
machine to take the cash
elmar tells how his mother left him to
which wendy empathizes because her
parents left two because she had been a
different kid they dance at a bar then
notice a girl is being harassed by a
group of men
wendy is determined to stop it by
inviting the men to come to the restroom
where wendy beats them all up elmar also
helps to electrocute a man who almost
attacks wendy
when coming home wendy gives the stolen
cash to lars saying it is to keep their
home to not be sold by the bank
the next day carl receives a new pair of
shoes and also sees that their swimming
pool is filled up as wendy is now able
to afford the water meanwhile the men
from the bar are interrogated in the
police station they claim to be beaten
by a woman to the police officer's
disbelief
however elmar's father takes over the
interrogation after knowing that
information and lets dr stern come in
she turns off the interrogation
recording tape and demands more
information about the super powered girl
who beat them
on the other hand wendy takes elmar to
mark's dwelling mark explains that more
people like them labeled as freaks and
psychos are held in a psychiatric
hospital which is actually more like a
prison for them
mark himself was there some years ago
the three of them then plan to release
those people they drive to the hospital
then wendy allures the guard then ties
him up then elmar turns off the
facility's electricity however other
guards almost catch up to them and they
run outside
when they are trapped elmar electrocutes
the guards to wendy and mark's shock
they argue that they cannot use their
powers to kill people but elmar believes
that the world needs to see them as
super-powered beings and fear them at
home wendy is confronted by lars he
suspects she is having an affair but
wendy brushes it off
meanwhile elmar scares his father's
girlfriend using his powers causing her
to leave wendy is meditating in the
swimming pool when she is confronted by
carl asking whether she and lars are
getting a divorce to which she replies
no
elmar goes to dr stern claiming he heard
voices by a homeless man in neptune
world abandoned water park turns out he
plans for the authorities to catch marek
and put him again in that hospital then
he goes to wendy's family's barbecue
party using his electroman costume
confesses her love for wendy imagining
that they can run away from the world
but stay together just like in the
comics wendy kicks him out then she
continues arguing with lars which ends
up in her throwing lars off the table
she goes out of the house in shock
at night elmar is talking to his father
persuading his father to hug him while
wendy watches from the garden
suddenly umar electrocutes his father
leaving him unconscious on the floor he
is surprised to see wendy it also
electrocutes her wendy wakes up in the
psychiatric hospital next to dr stern
all tied up
she screams at her for lying to her all
this time while dr stern argues that she
is only trying to protect wendy from
herself
she flashbacks to the tragedy at school
years ago when she was just a little
girl turns out she is angry at his
principle for taking away her walkman
and manages to throw him in his table
out of the room causing a big hole in
the wall
in the present wendy continues living
her days at the hospital taking
medications that suppress her powers and
meeting marek but he shows no response
to her
one day elmar comes to her apologizing
for his earlier actions and gives her a
walkman her favorite thing
however he continues convincing her that
they are the future of the world the
perfect kind of human being and that
they deserve to stay together
wendy ignores all his words while trying
to communicate with the hospital's
officer but to no avail when elmar
leaves him suddenly the lights go out
and wendy's door is open
she knows it is elmar's doing and
immediately rushes to leave the hospital
along with other patients dr stern and a
team of guards almost catch up to her
she argues that she has to stop elmar
but the guards are already preparing to
tie her down
dr stern prepares her gun and almost
shoots wendy when marek suddenly steps
in between them so the bullet goes
through
however new to taking medications marek
is not invincible anymore mark is
finally able to die meeting his family
in heaven
wendy quickly runs to her home finding
elmar has trapped lars and carl by
electric cables
he threatens wendy again but wendy is
not able to fight back because she has
been taking medications that suppress
her super strength when she is knocked
down lars throws rubber gloves at her so
she can touch and fight him without
being electrocuted she releases her
power and successfully throws elmar out
to her swimming pool elmar dies fried by
his own electricity
wendy embraces her son and husband
happily but realizes she cannot stay
with her family as the authority will be
looking for her she leaves to join other
freaks now planning to free more freaks
all over the world
meanwhile dr stern and the authorities
arrive at wendy's house to only find
lars and carl comfortably sitting next
to elmar's fried body
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching